[Musique]
est ce que ma mère est là il ya plus que
nous toi et nous avec qui tu étais au
parc ça n'est pas son nom juste que je
me suis perdu où as tu vu la jeune femme
de qui vous parlez
la joggeuse haut et de coups et violée
chaque jeune noir qui étaient dans le
parc l'année dernière est suspect je
veux que chacun de ces gamins
qu'est ce qui se passe avec mon fils
votre fils est impliqué dans un viol à
central park un noir c'est mignon c'est
un possédé une seconde enfants des
pythons vue violé cette femme
j'ai pas vu de femmes ni battue qui que
ce soit selon cliff kevin se veut aucune
femme tout de suite je veux voir mon
fils
[Musique]
quoiqu'il puisse dire j'ai rien fait je
sais
sonne
elles ne parviennent pas à recouper avec
les éléments principaux du crime tout ce
qu'il nous faut c'est qu'un seul des
discours coïncide avec les faits ces
vidéos ne sont pas aussi reprochable que
la police voudrait nous faire croire
dénonçons cette injustice il n'y a pas
la moindre première frénésie de ces
adolescents qui lui déchirer ses
vêtements innocent il n'a pas commis ces
crimes sans coupable
ils ont pas arrêté de nous mentir
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il fasse
d'autre j'ai fait des offres de rêve
ce raisonnement jeanne pas d'entendre
sipa
il se rapproche de moi ils sont de plus
en plus proche
c'est moi qui vais te ramener à la
maison
ils ont dit que si je joue un jour je
pourrai rentrer chez moi ici tout ce que
je voulais la police est prête à tout
faire
partir ou foot entre eux ils vont me
tuer
c'est ma vie
je pense qu'on devrait pas plaider
coupable pour un truc qu'on n'a pas fait
ok donc on va se battre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]